crime in the United States is escalating
at an alarming pace the statistics are
staggering urban centers are
oversaturated violence
and the wave of criminal activity has
overflowed suburban and rural areas
decision of main structure international
conspiracies a multibillion-dollar drug
trade knows the source and authorities
are helpless and Stockman's epidemic of
crime civilization is being pushed to
think to stem the rising
reestablish water extreme steps must be
taken the question becomes
we'll take them
Oh
I'm Jason Schroeder from Ubisoft San
Francisco I had the team put together a
trailer we just took some stuff from
snow drop and said make cool trailer in
it that's what it puts out so that's
kind of way that goes but all that chaos
all that scary stuff is totally true
thankfully the [ __ ] is up to the
occasion and who better to defend the
town of South Park and really Colorado
and really the world then superheroes or
kids in superhero costumes so like the
[ __ ] I need some help from friends
please welcome Trey Parker and Matt
Stone
look a comfy couch this is sweet I had
it brought later sit down ah no no it's
an exhausting walk always in it so let's
talk about the story everybody wants to
know what's going on in the fractured
but whole don't know yet yeah are you
skip well yeah it uh it picks up where
the stick of truth
what kind of left off you're the new kid
if you play stick of truth you would
know that and it you're the new kid who
moved to South Park and so the game is
really about who you are and you kind of
define who you are in South Park but
whereas the stick of truth was like a
fantasy send up and you end up being the
King in the end and the it's like the
next day in South Park that kids have
sort of switched up now they're playing
superheroes right right yeah and so we
we actually have a backstory that the
kids have been playing superhero but
they got into a big fight about
something so they're in the Civil War
the art of their pets and in fact a
Marvel wanted to call their movie
Captain America the fractured but whole
but we had already taken that name so
they had to they had to call their Civil
War true
after extremely true but also you know
we want to get into who you are as this
new kid and the fact that you know in
stick of truth' you really rose to being
cool because you became king but in this
game they've kind of switched games and
so you're back to being a douche bag
again right so let's see how that douche
bag was able to make it into confessing
real gameplay what the [ __ ]
who let this ordinary citizen into the
kid in there listen bro we are all
superheroes and you aren't so you can't
hang out with it
please do us all a solid and [ __ ] up hey
do not touch that that device can blow
up the entire Milky Way galaxy Jesus
[ __ ] mom the new kid is trying to play
with the king of ultimate destruction
you be nice to all your friends Eric you
could share good sharing about the
[ __ ] galaxies you can [ __ ] look dude
we already told you you can't they you
aren't a superhero you don't have a
costume you're on these super powers
freedom pals are adding people to their
franchise we should be adding key parts
this is dork like wearing a little crown
this is the negative er here - you
alright alright have a seat douchebag
not there that's Mysterio TV not there
either stupid all right in order to play
superheroes you have to have a superhero
persona then you can fill out your
character sheet on Kuhns - granny do you
have a cruiser gram page huh boy you're
not even on Q Instagram have well I
guess I can create one for you I believe
so the first thing we need to fill out
on your character sheet is your class
you know what kind of superhero are you
peter is like the magic or quick seven
like it yes Wow is really important to
us to be able to
you guys to be able to really create
your own superhero so that you saw on
that UI that there a dozen different
superhero classes you can choose from
you mix and match powers from those
classes and really make a superhero all
your own but what else is new in the
fractured but whole well I mean that's
obviously really I mean it just I mean
it's definitely more of a there's
definitely more of defining your
character and kind of in superhero
movies there's always like the intense
emotional center that like motivates why
you have to go out and fight crime so so
much as you can already tell it's a much
more spiritual more spiritus more
spiritual game it's so much more about
like there's a Lipstadt you know there's
actually a part of it that I'm really
proud of where there's a there's a gay
fish in South Park and he loves fish
sticks and the gay fish actually wants
you to help him get his mother into
heaven and so you get to journey up and
try to help this little gay fish get his
mom into heaven and you're all acting
like this shit's regular [ __ ] as hard
she's hard it was over I hope you all
saw the Kanye he didn't see the Kanye
thing that won't weaken but what no so
we you know
Cartman's the one who's kind of in
charge of telling each superhero what
their tragic backstory was that made
them made them a superhero and so this
is what he comes up with for Claire
right let's see it who let this guy go
enough anyway go easy on him you guys
he's had a tough life it's time they
learned you're a tragic backstory you
lay awake that night like so many other
nights you couldn't sleep because you
knew you weren't like the other kid you
walked to the mirror
you looked in the mirror and you felt
alone and that's when it happened a loud
noise you swore you could hear your
mother calling for help
you left your room
you left your room seriously do you just
walk through the door already but then
you finally reached your parents door
and what you saw when you open that door
changed your life forever and led you to
fighting crime you were too late because
when you open that door you saw you saw
your dad [ __ ] your man what but who
doesn't trust anyone because his dad but
his mommy couldn't do anything to stop
it
that doesn't make any sense I know how
could the person you trust do that to
the only other person you love Carthon
everyone's dad [ __ ] - everyone's mom huh
that's how it works stupid our dads
[ __ ] our mom's okay so does that mean
you're dead [ __ ] your mom cam yeah yes
my dad [ __ ] my mom that's why I'm here
don't steal his backstory dude that's
not cool
I can see I can see there's a lot of
people that relate to that story it's
very personal for us and apparently that
does touch a lot of people there's very
few people that can at least relate to
it at some level except for Jesus so we
got that one out so obviously that's
pretty brutal we've got another thing in
South Park that's brutal our combat and
we worked on that a lot together
yeah the combat system is much improved
from stick of truth and it's superhero
it's a superb game so it has the combat
is definitely the center yeah yeah it
was actually pretty cool because we and
the guys from Ubisoft would come down
and talk about what this game would be
and we would go back to my house
afterwards and play board games I'm a
big board gamer so we'd play all like my
favorite board games and tabletop
miniature type of games and figure out
how to you know we didn't we still
wanted to keep some of the term based
stuff because it it really makes it
easier to do story and so so we just
tried to do a big 4.0 version of stick
of truth right I mean it all those
sessions is a lot of very real clarity
that comes from that so what we ended up
putting in is they'll combat space and
time so let's talk about it first let's
talk about space
you're not restricted to a location
anymore now you can move to get into
tactical positions on your enemies
you can also move to get behind cover
you can push and pull enemies but they
can also do it to you you can knock them
into props and get a little extra damage
you can knock them into other characters
and get an extra attack you can use some
of your powers like tweak here to get
over obstacles so obviously using space
makes a big difference
next up is time in the first game your
parts were legendary now your parts are
so powerful that you can use them to rip
the fabric of time itself like Ghost
Recon
oh so
you use that to rearrange the turn order
mastering space inside makes a huge
difference I can't wait for you guys to
get your hands on it let's bring it out
with big volume
it's Wow - yeah that's critical
so then we did all that and now we do
the business part this is part o awesome
it's obviously been an amazing game for
us to work on and I think both of our
teams have been having a ton of fun and
we're almost done and now we have some
exciting news news for our South Park
fans before we go anyone who buys the
fractured but whole will get the stick
of truth for ps4 Xbox one and Steam for
free if you pre-purchase the game today
the game today a fractured but whole
that is and you can start playing stick
of truth right away so check out our
website and for information and about
our participating retailers right yeah
well that's great you don't so we made a
trailer if you want to see it sort of
shows what the boys are fighting about
that was the Civil War fractured but
whole part if you don't want to know the
release date probably - oh yeah yeah
music really put my money on December 6
the whole
thank you it gives everybody thanks good
why did we choose this life why did we
become superheroes we dedicate our lives
to fighting crime for one reason to make
a billion dollars on a superhero
franchise now let's go through the plan
one more time
first we start with a [ __ ] movie then we
do the super Craig movie then super
Craig and kun will join forces in the
human kite movies just as we start
ramping up Kenny's Netflix series how
come I have to have the Netflix series I
want a movie - you have a movie
mysterion you're in the third [ __ ] and
friends united movie after your Netflix
series yeah but he say he doesn't ever
get his own movie do I get my own movie
not everyone gets their own movie but
free time playing sucks if we want to
make billions of dollars and I think we
should start with the Tupperware movie
right start with a black superhero
Marvel is making a black superhero movie
yeah now they waited years to get to
that we follow their plan we do all the
real people first and we sneaked up that
guy in a phase-three how about we just
do movie starring all of us like all the
time
but then we're just rehashing the same
old material there's nothing wrong with
doing the exact same movie to start a
franchise okay JJ Abrams okay okay so
you're on Cartman's side he just likes
this plan because he gets to movies and
face one guy we have to just go with
this plan we don't even have one movie
yet how do they get
how did we grow so far apart
you go with the plan maybe we'll just go
and do our own franchise yeah yeah oh
you want civil war ease how would you
watch yeah dude Civil War [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you get out we'll make way more
money on our franchise your hair let you
know you get halfway through phase 1 on
your franchise TV comics
I thought civil war wasn't supposed to
happen to kill phase three
shut up super Craig
I didn't want to have to do this but you
leave me no choice did I just hear
someone use a microaggression